a few years ago my next guests were just
two dudes going on a surfing trip to
Bali which is awesome some fun it was an
adventure that changed their lives
though now it's changing the fate of the
planet please welcome from for ocean
Andrew Cooper and Alex Schulz today's
ride next are bad humans that's what
that is
[Laughter]
explain what for ocean is so for
Shenzhen ocean cleanup company that Anna
and I started about about three years
ago we were on a surfing trip in Bali
Indonesia saw crazy amounts of plastic
on the coastline in the ocean and we
wanted to do something about it so we
started by selling a bracelet made from
recycled materials and for every one
sold we'd remove a pound of trash in the
ocean it's amazing so why bracelets so
what we wanted to do is give anyone
anywhere in the world the opportunity to
clean the ocean regardless of how far
they lived from a coastline what
bracelets do is it it pretty much it's
gender-neutral and it goes with any
outfit it's also that reminder that
stays with you for every action or
decision you make you've to look down
your bracelet and you can make that
change that's really cool so cleaning up
our oceans is but it's important to you
both as well right now for us I mean an
Aquaman
[Applause]
it was kind of a no-brainer to go how
many pounds of plastic have you
recovered and recycled or soaked to say
our teams are working incredibly hard
seven days a week just recently passed
our 7 millionth pounds of trash in the
trash in the ocean and that's so much
trash just throw stuff out in the ocean
who are you that's actually a really
good point to bring up and it's not a
mysterious ship that's just cruising
offshore throwing the plastic over what
we're finding is that all the plastic
that we're collecting for our beach
cleanups and offshore on the boats is
it's coming from land so it's land-based
sources it's plastic that people are
using every day and it's not getting
discarded properly and it ends up back
in the ocean so one of our biggest
messages is like we got to stop it at
the source and stop it on land amen yes
I'm in so I feel like as humans
sometimes unless it directly impacts us
on a daily basis it's just out of sight
out of mind and it's gonna directly
impact us yeah at some point like we're
already is like open your eyes it's such
an important thing that y'all are doing
and I'm so thankful that y'all are here
so you have products as well that more
than race that's right people can buy
these and that money goes towards
helping right yes yes absolutely so
every product purchase we remove a pound
of trash from the ocean yep so we're
coming out so we started with a bracelet
that was kind of our first stepping
stone into you know starting for ocean
and now we're offering different tools
to reduce single use plastic
consumptions so reisel mugs reusable
bottles shopping bags
cutlery basically any item to reduce
single use plastic consumption how can
people help if people are home right now
going to not near the own I'm not doing
this like all their site go like what
can they really do so we kind of look at
that as three different ways that people
can help the ocean plastic crisis one is
reduce and eliminate your single use
plastic consumption so bringing that
bottle bringing that shopping bag
bringing that you know different tool to
so you don't have to continue to
purchase all these items wrapping some
loose plastic that's one way
number two is keep the conversation
going right all these posts on on social
media everybody having the conversation
it's an opportunity to raise awareness
about ocean plastic thing exactly
exactly what's happening and keep that
conversation going and number three is
we need to hold brands accountable right
if we can come up with sustainable
alternatives to that symbol use plastic
then we can count the solution like
Jason right here he's got the man and
Natalie which is offering water in
aluminum cans and giving people the
option to use aluminum which is 100%
recyclable over plastic so it's little
things like that what made you start
this yeah because I mean I live a single
use plastic life I mean I'm constantly
on an airplane I'm constantly in a hotel
traveling and you know on the airplane
you'll see as a coca-cola can there's a
beer can and sparkling water and then
it's this hot pink plastic bottle it's
like a shot of plastic it has three
different types the wrapper the bottle
then the cap it is not recyclable at all
yeah absolutely going into a landfill or
it's going into ocean like just ban it
it's not even in the plastic itself
going into your body that's about to say
I'm sorry good for you nothing I have so
much plastics in my blood we all you
have no idea it is directly impacting
you how much plastic is around us and it
seeps into us like just the stuff that
lies on the top of the ocean makes them
about 15% of what you're actually seeing
because the amount of nanotech I mean
like it'll it's going to blow your mind
and if you do the research
just on nano plastics but just on the
surface with I'm trying to do and these
gentlemen are trying to do just to
collect that it's a whole wave change we
just have to rethink everything that
we're doing and be conscious of it
something it's awesome that you have
that to constantly remind yourself but
like we've had things that we can do the
change I mean bring your water bottle
fill it up drink from home have your
Brita tap whatever you want to but when
you go out and you it's still getting
made so even if I do want to live a
clean life
seeing those plastic bottles are still
made and so my I want to be able to make
a change yeah go to these bigger
companies and go you need to change yeah
I want an option there's no options and
so I made mountain all new because it's
the way the unlocker managed well I got
to do
I want you to be a part of this global
movement as well so they're hooking each
one of you up with the four ocean
reusable gift bags as a has such a cool
thing I'm so in I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this